des petites briques en plastique moderne
pour rendre compte d'une histoire
vieille de 400 ans candolle et la
franche-comté appartenait au saint
empire romain germanique et que les rois
de france n'avait de cesse de vouloir la
conquérir
louis xiii puis le siège en vain durant
l'année 536 et il fallut attendre 774
pour que louis xiv arrache la belle cité
en même temps que besançon et là-bas
bout elle habite ici on est vivante 1
donc on connaît un peu si on descend son
mais en fin de compte lycée pour ses
mains liées et nous sommes devenus
français en même temps que vaud l'ain à
peu près l'histoire des sièges
successifs de la ville de dole et ses
fortifications sont au coeur de la
visite menée ce jour par nicole renier
les bateaux et par les avancées
triangulaire et les coupes ou mettant
ses morceaux de mur qui revit grâce que
certains vestiges sont aujourd'hui un
briquet dans l' architecture du centre
ville comme les âges qui soutenait une
porte d'entrée dans la ville la porte de
besançon
la porte n'était pas en paix flex
principal il y avait ce qu'on appelle
une chicane pour là aussi pouvoir
retarder l'ennemi c'est cela était
nécessaire
d'autres monuments épargné par vauban
après la conquête de la ville s'impose
encore aux passants comme la porte d'à
rend cette porte aux leurs c'est la
dernière des pertes records qui sait ce
parcours est une occasion pour les
visiteurs même de loi d'origine de re
découvrir leur environnement
on connaît pas tout sur l'histoire de
donna en fait je connaissais déjà pas
mal de choses mais après les
fortifications et tout quand même ça a
été détruit on n'arrivait pas trop avoir
un petit peu
arpenter les courtines et les bastions
c'est découvrir l'ancienne capitale du
comté sous un autre jour plus guerrier
valeureux et se souvenir que c'est là
que naquit selon la légende en 16 136 la
fameuse devise comptoir en toi n'est ni
ma foi